nous avons deux nouveaux agents dans ce
film qui sont des alliés de james bond le
monde s'est déplacé sur le lien du commandant tu étais
double o deux ans nomi est hautement
qualifié
légèrement arrogant tu me gênes je vais te
mettre une balle dans le
genou celui qui fonctionne
il y a une jeune femme à santiago je veux que
vous vous rencontriez bonjour
tu es en retard
bonjour mon agent cubain elle est intense
j'ai eu beaucoup de scènes d'action
Dieu merci j'avais une équipe de cascadeurs incroyable
ils m'ont fait suivre une véritable
formation militaire je voulais vraiment bien faire les choses
et  on dirait que je savais ce que je faisais
pas le temps de mourir représente le changement nous voyons
tellement d'exemples différents de
femmes fortes dans ce film
et être badass est à ce non
deux
vous